alright guys here we are the Smithsonian
Air and Space Museum in Chantilly
Virginia and today is Tommy's birthday
[Music]
now we got the whole family here we got
two sets of grandparents here we are
going to have a good time is the World
War two course there see the little
holes in the wings that's worth three
machine guns on each side so tell me
what's your favorite plane hi hi Jacob
see look there's bombs right there they
probably took the explosives out of them
so they can't blow up
[Music]
Donna over on Jamie roll around on the
ground we'll come back later and check
on you yeah it's the sr-71 blackbird
right there
[Music]
hey Tom you know this is a Decepticon
they just have to come transformer
Nathan that's where the planes farts
come out no I has the logo of the skunk
on the side because it was made by skunk
works via camera and his guns right in
there aren't there and there's that
one's got guns too this is called the
Sidewinder missile that's named after a
snake this is the intruder it's got two
seats side-by-side yes it's Felix the
Cat with the bomb
seat is playing behind us that's the
f-14 let me tell you a story about a man
named goose and a man named amber
Zeus was killed when they tried to eject
and he died in his arms in the water
that's when he began to question himself
but over Libya maverick skills would be
necessary and that's when he would
finally shake the ghosts of booths is
down
you save the day
oh there's the Cobra I stick a little
piece of over there so then they can
just leave forward and it's their nose
ask them where they put the velcro in
their butt itches I've watched every one
of your videos oh my goodness
all right apparently we ran into some
superfans here
make sure to LIKE and subscribe yeah
they really were excited what hey look
at this it's the termite missile this is
the matador cruise missile hey Tommy you
having a good birthday spaceship see all
the silver stuff on the outside of the
spaceship that's duct tape yep
a satellite yeah it's the final
countdown that's the machine that
injected Princess Leia with the truth
serum because we will discuss the
location of your hidden rebel base
they've got everything in this museum
[Music]
yeah the older I get the more I judge
the museum's quality based on the number
and quality of their seats
that's a remote-controlled car that
landed on Mars
that's a Gemini heat shield you can see
all the marks from where it burned
coming through the atmosphere
yeah this is where the astronauts go
camping that's where they changed your
diaper yep
this is the model of the ship from Close
Encounters of the Third Kind this means
some reason I have a hankering for
mashed potatoes now that's a rocket look
it goes all the way up
that is a secret Nazi bomber playing see
it's a little helicopter that you can
just sit in these are German what yeah
little tiny helicopters that'd be pretty
cool to go fishing in wouldn't it
check it out Tommy this is the nakajima
this is the key shushing then
[Music]
that's a big bomber it is cute hey Tommy
see ya got airplane with the bicycle
tires so we could build one of those and
fly it around and go fishing would you
like to build one of those airplanes why
don't you go ask your mom if we can go
build one
check it out we're underneath the
Concorde this plane above us is the
Concorde it used to fly from New York to
London faster than the speed of sound I
didn't fly this model of the Falcon and
I flew five other corporate jets I got
to fly occasionally in this corporate
jet it was fun think of me like that
candy yeah it's the blimp this little
thing is right there he was dangling
from a balloon all the way to outer
space that's that's an airplane video
game do you want to go in the simulator
with Grandpa
[Music]
this is where they restore the airplanes
that they put in the museum is that cool
or what this is the one that dropped the
atomic bomb there's been fun you
enjoying your birthday pizza Nathan are
you a bumblebee this is tres leches cake
and we're adding ice cream to it which
makes it cuatro leches you don't want to
do our tornado kick that escalated
quickly how about this you don't you
should settle this armwrestling match
come on Quinn lock it up let's see what
you we're going over the top one two
three
[Music]
tell you about a presence Tommy you got
quite the hole there Tommy thanks for
coming over guys Tommy did you have a
great birthday yes if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boy's youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watch
[Music]